good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Bret Baier one week after the deadly
shooting at a South Florida high school
that claimed 17 lives and forever
changed many times that survivors
brought their demand for new gun
controls and new security measures to
the State Capitol in Tallahassee
meanwhile here in Washington just
moments ago President Trump finished up
with the White House billed as a
listening session that really turned
into an open exchange of ideas and
emotion we have Fox team coverage
tonight Steve Harrigan is in parkland
Florida with the students story down
there but we start off with chief White
House correspondent John Roberts on the
North Lawn even John Brackett evening to
you was another extraordinary moment at
the White House the nation allowed to
listen in his students from Douglass
High and the parent of one of the
children killed there appealed to
President Trump did not let the Douglass
school shooting be like all the others
that this nation has seen to actually
make a difference this time in the State
Dining Room today six students from
Douglass High School and their parents
brought to Washington by the Department
of Education
nothing ever that horrible should ever
have to happen to you from school maybe
compromise on some solutions so this
never has to no child no person in this
world will ever have to go something
through so horrific this solution is not
gonna be a singular thing it's gonna be
multifaceted it's not left and right
it's not political it's a human issue
and I don't understand why I could still
go in a store and buy a weapon of war
the students telling stories of the
terror they went through as the gunman
blasted his way down the corridor and
from the father of meadow [ __ ] who
was killed at Douglass High the anguish
and anger of a parent who will never see
their child again should have been one
school shooting and we should have fixed
it and I'm pissed because my god I'm not
gonna see again she's not here she's not
here she's at in North Lauderdale like
whatever it is King David
Cemetery also at the meeting pair
rates of children killed at Sandy Hook
elementary the parents of Rachel Scott
the first student killed at Columbine
and students and teachers from DC high
schools President Trump was in listening
mode but also coming to the meeting with
ideas of his own before President Trump
convened the meeting protesters marched
through Washington to the White House to
observe a moment of silence to read the
names of the fallen and to demand the
president do something concrete to
address the epidemic of school and mass
shootings in America president Trump
pledged that the Douglass school
shooting won't be like all the others
that it will result in changes among the
things he is considering raising the
federal minimum age to buy a rifle from
the current 18 addressing the issue of
mental illness and tightening up
background checks to make sure red flags
don't fall through the cracks
the president also suggested military
veterans could be hired to provide
security in schools you'd have a lot of
people that be armed they'd be ready
they're professionals they may be
Marines that left the Marines left the
army left the Air Force and they're very
adept at doing that you'd have a lot of
them and they'd be spread evenly
throughout the school this is just the
first listening session that the
president will have at the White House
this week tomorrow he meets with state
and local officials and then next week
he meets with the nation's governors to
talk about the problem Brett we have
been here many times in the past but at
least on the surface this time is
beginning to feel different definitely
different and we'll see where this goes
John another topic we heard from White
House chief of staff John Kelly about
security clearances specifically dealing
with
Jared Kushner the president's son-in-law
you'll remember last Friday Brett chief
of staff John Kelly issued a five-page
memorandum saying that people who have
security clearances that are pending as
of June 1st are prior to that will lose
their in term security clearance as of
this Friday that apparently does not
apply to Jared Kushner because the
changes that he made in his FS f-86
clearance form which is the background
form that you fill out to get your full
security clearance that was not
submitted until after June the first the
chief of staff John Kelly said and the
press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
said that Jared Kushner will continue to
fulfill his job which involves looking
at some of the most highly classified
information that passes through the
White House but Kelley also said that he
is going to review this every month or
so so if Kushner does not get his full
security clearance soon he may not be
out of the woods Brett okay John Roberts
live in the North Lawn John thank you